les réseaux sociaux sont la principale
source d'information des jeunes mais sur
ces plateformes des images sont parfois
détournés et certaines informations
peuvent être erronées il y avait le truc
où un an dro the vaccinés si on met
notre téléphone mais c'est un col est un
mouvement se veut tourné beaucoup sur le
résilier avec la classe de seconde 5 du
lycée paul valéry nous apprendrons à
vérifier les contenus suspects qu'ils
croisent quotidiennement et à déceler le
vrai du faux j'espère y en a pour les
impressions face à ce niveau hu
retrouvez l'émission spéciale de info ou
intox sur france 24 et france 24 points
comme